I don't when - welcome to this video
playing I'm les here with white let's do
something else okay I've got an English
opening yeah I had a game before that
that I did not upload I mean I did start
the recording but to terminate it rather
quickly and it was an odd game where I
was feeling from one that cheating was
involved yeah at the end I don't think
that was the case but that whole video
was kind of screwed because I was
starting thinking from start to finish
that something was odd it probably it
wasn't but but so weird anyway I decided
to scratch that one and and starting new
game I felt it was kind of a bit besides
the point if I the whole video is about
me renting or renting is wrong with
asking myself if this is a cheat or not
iam that it's really yeah I felt a bit
of pointless and the promise simply
shouldn't do this kind of arguing any
video maybe after the games finish but
not during the game okay so here we have
a
benoni reversed but no NIEM
there's one thing that I don't like it's
my bishop won't be too that is really
wrong many other things are nice I've
got a very nice Bishop on g2 that is
unopposed this is also why I took the
bishop on d7 that didn't look too
impressive but it means that I will be
really strong here on the light squares
six
hmm yeah not not a move I expected
let's put it like that what is the idea
even p6
[Music]
for no clue
to toggle their own define I really
don't understand it
p5 okay not something that I had on the
radar okay if he takes rook takes looks
pretty awful I'm threatening to take
winning material maybe I should have
taken root c1 yeah I felt like if I
can't get to force this I can be quite
happy Queen side stays closed and I will
be able to regroup the bishop wire c1 so
Bishop comes to c1
that's not too bad to have protected
pawn on c4 protected passer and
currently it's not exactly close to
bring in Knight to c5 he has to move
many piece of screen bishop knight on f6
interesting question is what I should do
with my knight
I don't want to just trade on e4 not
that this is necessarily bad but I felt
I might have something better
g4 g5 is also possibility it sorry h4 h5
that's what I was trying to say for h5
and then black has to has to return
and move it Knight to f3 it wouldn't be
all that bad for go here and then Knight
f3 Knight 7 I take e 5 with the Queen it
looks a bit odd it's a bit of an odd
square
ok now Knight is 7 is close to trapping
the Queen I can go to age 3 now it is
yeah t5 even at 94 94 looks best
[Music]
yeah I'm close to Wow
wanted to say I'm close to posing some
concrete threats now and he plays this
shocker six assists you see wriggling
himself out is Knight f6 no one can take
on e5 okay
Knight f6 SE v e5 on the check I have
Bishop e3
I probably take no does not take okay
thought he would take one d3 but he
didn't
maybe I should have gone to should be
six
it doesn't help all that much as I
cannot take a five
we got 12 seconds it's not not a not
endure another Lord
okay I was thankful for the increment in
situations like that yeah this can make
some moves and don't have to completely
panic yeah I got an extremely nice
position down the whole conversion was a
bit odd maybe yeah here I should take
and play Roxy one that's even stronger
it's very difficult now for him to make
a move I'm threatening a four here and
there's enormous pressure Queen a seven
seems to be a move that does not lose
material I don't even understand why I
be creative it's rendered promises okay
so that after a four which is not even
good he can go back okay yeah here
before us at least not losing material
form but it's a strategically terrible
opposition public I have all them
all the assets and you can kind of argue
about the ordinal probably f5 was
shocking really
okay Bishop h6 is winning yeah I didn't
really have time at the moment and this
also looked pretty strong yeah
important this that this is not working
due to every five otherwise would be a
bit awful yeah like yes you don't want
to do this and now I'm I'm winning but
it is it is still irritating yeah I
thought you would take b3 there was no
real reason not to do it yeah I was
still a bit in the panic mode don't
think I screwed it up
you know so I mean that was reasonable
for the time situation it was reasonable
I think most interesting moment was here
when I should take even now that that's
better
okay queen eight seven Holt's doesn't
lose material but blacks position is
very hard to coordinate okay guys thanks
for watching